why don't we speak next you know it's
always fraught to know where we go next
when it comes to phone calls but I
believe we're going to go to Ali from
Scotland uh Ollie welcome to the program
oh yeah thanks for having me David
pleasure
it's great to be on and I actually had a
couple of questions but I'll keep it to
one just in the interest of time
um so the growing debates around you
know transgender youth transgender and
you know adolescence is all over social
media right now and even in mainstream
American discourse and I wonder what
where do you think it's going and you
know at the very top level obviously
every Trump rally he says the infamous
line and then no one should be allowed
to teach transgender to our children
much and it's like what does that even
mean
I know exactly like from a grammatical
point of view and then yeah it just
doesn't make any sense like most of the
stuff he says but where do you think is
going you know here's my hope okay I'm
gonna give you here's my hope of where
the anti-tran stuff among the right is
going my hope is that this is a
temporary stop on the
discrimination and marginalization train
there was a time when the right was
obsessed with gay men they they never
really were that worked up about
lesbians you might remember but like
when I started doing the show they were
obsessed with gay men and now they've
mostly moved on from gay men now trans
is the issue and specifically it's what
they call quote men in women's sports is
a heavy part of it also the things they
claim are being done with regularity
when it comes to Children which are not
actually being done right now that's
their focus and it's really tough for
the people that are being targeted and
marginalized by that my hope is that
eventually they will Tire of the subject
then move on to something else the
problem is who's the next Target right I
feel bad for whoever the next Target is
going to be but there it's just it's
been a shift they've gone from obsession
with going after gay men
now it's the trans stuff there will be a
next thing I don't know what it will be
and when but I I hope they move on soon
although I also want to protect whoever
the next targets are going to be
yeah I think that's absolutely right I
mean I wonder if there's a religious
um you know component to this and and
terms of you know protect the children
save the children the left as they say
the left are attacking our children they
want to sexualize Children which as we
know you know it's not happening you
know they can pick a couple of people on
Tick Tock or write a couple of you know
extreme people in a couple of schools
and the whole of America and they say
this is what the left is doing that's
what they're doing but you know it's
part of it I want to add one item to
this Ollie part of it is
that a lot of the anti-trans stuff when
it comes to kids ties in to their
conspiracy theories about pedophile
Democrats and child sex trafficking and
that type of thing so it's sort of each
has signal boosted the other in a really
convenient way for for these right
Wingers
absolutely no that's absolutely right I
just I wonder where that aspect's going
you know it helps me not the biggest
issue yep and it's not the biggest issue
for me personally either right but you
know it's just something I'm interested
in hey Ollie I have a question for you
the other day someone told me that when
they were in Scotland they ate something
called neeps and tatties do you have any
idea what that is
yeah so that is a Scottish dish which I
don't even like I mean if any Scottish
person's last thing they don't want to
kill me for that but it's basically
potatoes and haggis mixed into one
hey which signs you know taste just as
appealing as it says it's really not
great when you say is it like you mash
up the potatoes and mix in the Haggis I
don't even get what you do I mean to be
honest I've not had it in such a long
time oh it's mainly you know more of an
old-fashioned thing got it but um yeah I
mean some people would literally get
their fork and mash it into this one
substance and say that they enjoy it so
wow yeah I wouldn't recommend it David
all right well listen if I go to
Scotland I will look for other forms of
Cuisine definitely all right thank you
for the call I appreciate it thank you
very much Nixon there goes Ollie from
Scotland a very very powerful message